GOVERNOR WHO IS JUST INAUGURATED
LAST YEAR FINALLY COMES TO A
CLOSE THIS EVENING.
>> Bret: THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MATT.
TWO ARE OTHER TOP STORY, ABC HAS
CANCELED ROSEANNE BARR’S TV
SHOW.
THAT COMES FOLLOWING A TWEET
FROM A COMIC WHICH MOST PEOPLE
FOUND NOT FUNNY AT ALL BUT
RATHER OF    ABHORRENT.
>> ROSEANNE BARR WAS ON TOP OF
THE WORLD.
HER RESURRECTED SHOW WAS A HUGE
CHECK FOR ABC.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT DOGS JO.
HE SHOOK THINGS UP.
>> LOOK AT ROSEANNE, LOOK AT HER
RATINGS.
>> BUT HOURS LATER, SHE WAS
CANCELED OVER UGLY COMMENTS.
COMMENTS THE NETWORK CALLED
ABHORRENT, REPUGNANT AND
INCONSISTENT WITH OUR VALUES.
THE OFFENDING TWEET SAID IT,
MUSLIM BROTHERHOOD AND PLANET OF
THE
"PLANET OF THE APES" HAD A BABY,
EQUALS BJ.
WHEN TWITTER USERS CALLED THE
LINE RACIST, SHE RESPONDED THAT
MUSLIMS ARE NOT A RACE.
SHE TWEETED LATER THAT SHE WAS
MAKING A JOKE BEFORE FINALLY
SAYING THIS.
I APOLOGIZE TO VALERIE JARRETT
AND ALL AMERICANS.
I AM TRULY SORRY ABOUT MAKING A
BAD JOKE ABOUT HER POLITICS AND
HER LOOKS.
BUT THE OUTRAGE MOUNTED.
ACTRESS ACTRESS WANDA SYKES THAT
SHE WOULD NOT BE RETURNING.
ABC MUST TAKE ACTION NOW.
MANY OTHER COMEDIANS HAVE
SURVIVED OFFENSIVE JOKES.
STEPHEN COLBERT MADE A CRACK
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
KATHY GRIFFIN IS MOUNTING A
COMEBACK AFTER POSING WITH A
BLOODIED TRUMP MASK.
WANDA SYKES HERSELF ONCE CALLED
RUSH LIMBAUGH THE 20TH HIJACKER
WHO FAILED TO SHOW UP ON 9/11.
IT PROMPTED BY BOB IGER, CEO OF
PARENT COMPANY DISNEY TO SAY,
THERE’S ONLY ONE THING TO DO
HERE, AND THAT WAS THE RIGHT
THING.
ABC ACTED WITH STUNNING
SWIFTNESS TO PROTECT ITS BRAND
ALTHOUGH THE SHOW HAD BEEN VERY
LUCRATIVE.
IN THIS HYPER POLARIZED TWITTER
ERA, A NETWORK’S REPUTATION CAN
BE TARNISHED AND A TOP STAR
KENDA STRIPPED DESTRUCT.
>> Bret: WE ASKED HER MULTIPLE
TIMES ABOUT IT AND SHE REPLIED
TO THESE NUMEROUS QUESTIONS BY
SAYING THE PRESIDENT IS FOCUSED
ON OTHER THINGS.
AND YOU CAN USE THE HASHTAG A